welcome everybody to yoga session lived
in Russia is because what seeing real
time traffic problems without saying
grexit the first two talks the talk bye
bye javi Newman about the Large Hadron
Collider in the data issues and then the
talk by Richard Allen about crowd
sensing of the earthquakes I sort of
felt bang there's all my content gone
which I guess is is great from the point
of view of conference organization it
means that there are people I'd never
heard of it we're doing it very closely
related work on the other hand it means
I have to try and find something
different to say but then luckily there
was the the talk by Edward Lee the
absolutely fascinating talk about
real-time control and so so that made it
clear to me that what I really ought to
do is talk about polemic rather than
rather than reconstruction so I'm going
to essentially position myself as the
anti Edward Lee and trying to explain
why I think that that approach is not
what we need for this a certain class of
problems and let me start with
trying this on
and this is a book the cathedral in the
bazaar it's it's a book from a
completely different domain now it's a
book about linux and open source and how
you program it by the author of
fetchmail one of the standard utilities
he wrote he wrote this big long ish
essay he wrote it about development
models for how you build open-source
software specifically he was interested
in the contrast between what he called
the Cathedral stellar development which
is how Emacs was built versus the
bizarre cell which is how linux was
built the cathedral style is where you
have a small group of people who build a
perfect structure and then release it
once they feel this ready that's how we
max development has gone on his
inversion 24 or something by now indeed
Cid's worked very well for emacs and he
contrasted to the bizarre model of
development where it's a open
development anyone can contribute all of
the development is showing incrementally
as you go along and his essay was
specifically about alternate styles for
developing open-source software but but
the metaphor cathedral versus bazaar is
so good that it took on a life of its
own like all good metaphors do so here's
a cathedral here's a bizarre Apple when
when when they decide their new product
is ready they will release it and
everyone will have the perfect thing in
their hand I want to talk about
cathedral and bazaar of data as it
applies specifically in my context to
traffic problems what have we heard
about we heard about the Large Hadron
Collider I think those pictures are very
self-consciously made to mimic the Rose
windows I think that was one is from
Lincoln Cathedral so it was the first
dog this is a gigantic the expensive
absolutely precision engineered system
versus the bizarre this is the the
collect data from the crowd try and get
your stuff out as if see if people
adopted cope with the noise cope with
the uncertainty so that's that's perhaps
really what more on this title for my
talk would have been at least the first
off anecdotes from the data bizarre i'm
going to talk through several cases that
we've seen of working with data that
arises in traffic problems and from that
i will attempt to draw lessons about
what I think what I think we should be
doing when we are handling the sort of
data um here's a just small experiment
you can do anyone who has a iphone
android can just download a sensor
logging piece of software that's what i
did i started at home i had android and
deny phone in my pocket though they were
both top end models at the time they
were bought which is quite a while again
i was the roughly contemporary and i
walked around a few blocks and I
collected GPS traces and I've just drawn
the line indicating although the
readings I got you can see when I'm
inside it it's jumping around when I'm
went into a bike shop here I think it
was that jumped around it's great that
we have this but just the traces on
their own they won't be terribly useful
if I want to ask a question like how far
did I walk each one of these dots is 10
meters apart so you can you can see the
the uncertainty and it's not not really
tight enough if we're going to use it to
ask questions like which side of the
street should the uber driver come and
pick me up on your in a complicated city
with one-way systems that becomes quite
a time-saving issue and I guess another
question from this a meta question is
why is this so crummy when commercial
GPS by commercial GPS I mean the stuff
that farmers use surf that military uses
and stuff that ships use that gets sent
to me to precision so the satellites can
give you centimeter precision you can
get receivers which gives you centimeter
precision and what we have in our phone
is off by 20 meters
and there's one blindingly obvious
answer which is phones are much cheaper
phones are cheaper they get a lock
faster to get sent me to prison you
probably need to wait for a few hours
you may need to set up specialized
equipment and these are watering ly
expensive to get centimeter precision so
you don't want that in your phone this
is the the first rule cheap and fast and
noisy will get more widespread than
precise and expensive that's one lesson
that's very easy lesson to learn from
this but I wanted to dig in a bit
further let's let's let's learn a bit
more about this data and when your phone
reports its position it reports a
position estimate and also reports say
uncertainty estimated the uncertainty is
measured in meters here I've drawn the
uncertainty measurements from the
Android in green and the iOS in red
saree afraid the colors keep on changing
from side to side
they just plain out differently the the
iphone is completely confident in it in
its mistakes the android doesn't doesn't
pretend to be accurate but that this is
giving something that's a mate the
phones will tell you this one thing that
i got from looking at this is you look
at this new think yourself no way is
that ever iid noise and you used to
Kalman filters and so on you assume
independent Gaussian noise that is
absolutely not guess who knows so so
what am I seeing if the noise isn't
Gaussian if the noise has all these
correlations what can I do with it if I
want to do any cleaning up obviously
that means I can't use Kalman filtering
because because doesn't work there
I I did some experiments my best guess
for what what this is doing what I'm
showing here the iOS reading is in red
again and on top of that i did a Kalman
filter and i did a Kalman filter in
which the state which you're updating
his location como velocity and for my
Kalman filter I assume that the velocity
has iid increments so I tried a variety
of different Kalman filters you could
say let's take be location and assume
that state has iad increments that
doesn't fit this very well you could try
this you could try alternative models in
fact the iphone operating system it
gives you a choice of 4 profiles about
how you want location reported and this
is just the high precision profile which
is different from the driving problems
and as well what they are it's not
really documented but anyway after
having tried a variety of different
equations Kelman estimating equations
this is my best guess about what's going
on it seems to fit roughly what the data
is doing but that's sort of this is a
really sensible filter it is pretty good
at keeping up to date with where you are
it's very laggy if you make a sharp turn
it sort of has the feeling of skidding
when you go round the corners because it
assumes that velocity has idea
increments and if if you suddenly make a
shot turn that that doesn't fit its
model anyway the thing to take away from
this is that the iOS is not reporting to
a sensor reading it is reporting to a
pre pressure sensor reading and no one
will ever tell you what the
pre-processing is and here's another
experiment I did I was sitting in my
flat rounded up here and I sat down and
had them both on for 12 minutes and I
recorded all the GPS sampled I think
frequency once every 10 seconds or 30
seconds or whatever it was and here I'm
just plotting longitude reported
longitude the full x-axis is a range of
30 meters and this is a histogram of the
longitude readings that the Android gave
and this is a histogram of longitude
readings that iOS gave
so what do you conclude from this well
you might conclude iOS has really zoomed
in and married me down very precisely
that would be just wrong GPS does not
give you answers this accurate when
you're inside the answer is that iOS
decided it would be more helpful to lock
onto a single value and keep on
reporting that value even though it's
wrong then it would be to report the
messy truth so that's another lesson a
convenient falsehood Apple thinks is
more useful than the messy truth
I'm question and when you say by truth
that means it says the revealing the
truth that it isn't actually capable of
determining where you are yes the truth
is best known by the device exactly
right I'm going to get yes it would be
nice to have an article but yeah thnkx
um so which of these two is better I
don't know if that's something you can
answer objectively but but it is at
least clear why Apple decided to do this
an apple let me go back to the cathedral
and bazaar the original essay this is a
quote from from eric raymond there have
been many other software products that
combined a cathedral mode core and a
bizarre mode toolbox he was thinking of
Lisp where they have a match for the
central editor is is is highly
controlled and there's a whole load of
list packages which are distributed the
action the ferment the innovation mostly
takes place in the open part of the tool
or a large and varied community continue
with it it was also thinking of matlab
there but but it plays just as well to
to iOS Apple made a decision that they
will have a cathedral mode core and they
will do everything they can to nurture a
development could develop a community
for writing apps and so they make
certain judgments about what will help
nurture that developer community 11
judgment as I said is they think it will
be easier for app writers to flourish if
they give them a clean falsehood rather
than Messi truth they they another
reason behind the Kalman filtering which
i think is quite clever Apple does
Kalman filtering before it gives you any
answer therefore there is no point in me
writing an app which will probe the GPS
every two seconds and it's already been
smooth I'm not going to get any extra
information by repeatedly probing there
for Apple by pre-processing has removed
any incentive for me to repeatedly probe
the hardware and therefore apps will
tend to have better a better battery
life
I think it was quite clever of them that
Apple does go to extraordinary lengths
to make it easier developers to get
things right the other thing that that
Apple did they seem to have two modes
one is the Kalman filtering road the
other mode is the latching on mode and a
polite i think is positioning this
because they say okay that in two years
time the phones could well have
radically different hardware and there
will be new tricks invented along the
way I'm going to present a very simple
interface which only reports position
and I'm not going to give any promises
about what it does so that when phones
upgrade hopefully the apps will not have
have been customized so much that they
really use a processing hard-coded
towards the specific hardware so so
apple also thought to make it resilient
to the future we want to obfuscate the
signal
those are the first two lessons cheek
noisy fast beats out precise and
expensive why phones have crummy GPS
hardware it's why that that smart shake
system could get has the potential to
get readings from us go to Nepal whereas
the expensive seismographs when second
rule data has been processed and no one
will tell you how
and okay let's switch switch to a
different example now this is something
that the logic touch them and I want to
go through this example a bit more cuz
it it's nice in it also illustrate
certain points and this is from a subway
system I called it the Bakerloo line
it's not actually in London it's not
actually in Singapore and I'm not going
to say where it is but what I've drawn
here is several stations along the line
I've given the names bakerloo Great
Portland Street using Kings Cross London
names and time of day and i chunked time
into 15-second chunks and I recorded the
number of people who tap in or out at
each station and well this is obviously
a busiest station but there's not very
much to see ok so let's try something a
little bit cleverer with this data in
this version on drawing the same data
[ __ ] i'm drawing tap-ins above the line
and I'm drawing tapouts below the line
tap-ins you'd expect people would derive
as some random process Thank You Boston
process tapouts you would expect there
to be spikes of tapouts every time the
train arrives train arrives lots of
people disembark at the same time that
gives a spike
sometimes the spikes look reasonably
clear sometimes aren't quite clear
enough so that was the next trick that
Balaji mentioned you look at the roots
what I did here is I looked at the
entire route diagram and then based on
the start location and the end location
I can make a pretty good guess did this
person definitely take the line I'm
interested in or did they arrive at the
station from some other on some other
line and if I narrow my attention down
to definite swipe outs on a specific
line then suddenly we start seeing these
these clusters very sharply and then you
can stitch them together and you can say
well the passage a train arrived here
shortly beforehand the train arrived
here shortly beforehand the trainer idea
so you can just stitch these together
and do work out exactly where the train
was so this is this is the
reconstruction stuff that we heard about
from first perm from in the large hadron
collider context than from Balaji this
morning okay so that's reconstruction
but it's not that's not the point of
this data of this story the point of
this story is this is us trying to work
out where the trains are based on the
tap in tap out records and why bother
surely they have systems which record
where the trends are shal you can just
go and interrogate a database and tell
us where the trends are when we did that
this is the picture that we got so here
we actually received the recordings the
the from there that signaling sauce pro
of when the trains arrived at each
station I've drawn so these diagonal
lines going up represent a train and the
outbound direction this represents a
train on the inbound direction along
this line the their official timings
mostly match the clusters of tappet of
tapouts but not entirely there are some
just plain riches in the data when I
looked at the data more closely I did
see quite a few cases whether were just
bizarre glitches towards the end of the
line what I think was going on there was
that they have performance targets and
they measure the performance targets by
asking what
ntage of trains arrived at the
destination within a certain time of
starting out and if you have a train
which is running late and you want to
meet your performance target what you is
yuri label your train so it doesn't
appear in the data set as a little a
train that's my guess so anyway that's
why I'm not going to tell you which
which which country this data came from
is not from Singapore it's not from
Washington it's not from anyone who paid
us either I'm going to tell you that
much so what we learn from this what
problem is that the data they tell us
the data they tell you will people
people lie in their data they don't tell
you what's in their data sometimes they
don't know sometimes they're lying to
you the other problem to actually get
them to tell us this trend 02 took an
awful lot of work they have a system
which was built goodness knows when I
know whenever people built subway
systems they have legacy systems it they
said it took them to query the platform
times on a single platform so to agree
the train times on a single platform
they had to query it in chunks of half
an hour on a platform by platform basis
and then receive a huge number of files
and institutions them together so
whenever you try and get useful data
about this sort of thing you're tangled
up with legacy systems this was a story
so what's eat people out seven a.m. and
stay around for an hour to and get this
understand why it's so hard to get this
data is I could ask the company that to
go out to the station you could it just
got people to go and stand there and get
the Trentonian so typically they'd send
our people with clipboards to get the
timings or they get the passenger counts
and I do this as a sample because it's
too expensive to do it continuously so
they take a sample once periodically
legacy systems when when even when there
is data this is a newsroom mpr which
which was pointing out that the US
nuclear weapons launch system still runs
on 1970s computers with 8 inch floppies
so so all sorts of data is hidden away
in systems like that
okay so so lesson 1 the reason why we
were able to do the reconstruction based
on tap in tap out records is tap in tap
out is directly related to building you
can be confident that any data system
which is directly connected to building
will have very high quality data any
data system which is not directly
related to building you will have to
cope with legacy and stuff and noise and
nonsense and let me give another example
of something funny to do with billing
this is an example from Illinois Tollway
they have a system of all right on the
tollway at each of these plazas they
have an overhead gantry like this it's
not like when you're coming south on on
the Golden Gate Bridge where whether the
thing widens you go through separate
lanes each with its own but think that
they put the gantries over the entire
street and as you drive past it scans
your RFID think so ideally you don't
slow down at all you just drive through
and it measures what's going on these
countries scan your RFID tags in the
current they collect your vehicle ID and
the speed and the time at which you
passed each plaza I jumped into the data
ferb plaza 35 I did one of these classic
this is a graph where it's got through
sort of put on the x-axis flow on the
x-axis and speed on the y-axis and I've
drawn the line oh there's a dotter to
every 15 minute point in time and I've
labeled them so it that as 4pm 415-430 5
and so on around about 4 15 there's a
massive drop in speed
and
wanted to look in more so let me switch
to an animation
keep your playing and talk you through
what I've done here there's Plaza 35
that's the point where we have speed and
time stamp records I drum 1 dot per car
and I've given each car well there are
cars in blue butters in green freight
vehicles in red H dot represents a
vehicle and I've given it a tail which
extends back one minute in its covers
all the distance that that vehicle
traveled in one minute this this
representation has the happy behavior
that if you just add up the total amount
of ink in a vertical slice it will tell
you the throughput at that spot in time
so I don't have to do any bothersome bin
stuff into fishing minute chunks bin
stuff in 200 meter areas i just get
instantaneous readings of throughput in
vehicles per minute at each point along
the bar at the top it's telling us the
speed the average speed of the vehicles
in the display around about 60 65 miles
an hour and I drew a reference line
there's no formal reference line it's
just somewhere are now we see it unless
let's play that once more
right happy happy happy 60 miles an hour
how many legs no I think it's for Lent
now this is what the onset of congestion
looks like speed drops to 20 miles an
hour
that's what congestion looks like well
what's interesting here though is that
if you look at the throughput lines
before and after this is just a
reference line to keep your eyes level
at the time of congestion there are
these waves but the average throughput
is barely being affected at all I don't
know enough about the transport dynamics
I know that when speed changes and
density changes i expect throughput to
change throughput has barely change at
all in this this is a phenomenon of
massive reduction of speed no real
reduction in throughput yeah that's a
nice little demo of what congestion
looks like
this phenomenon of large drop in speed
negligible drop in throughput
let me get into it another way at those
times of congestion or in that nasty
period of day it's got on set around 4pm
it clears up sometime around a p.m. i
was looking at speeds around Plaza 35
and and speed at Plaza 35 really really
suffered it went down to 20 miles or so
but we also have multiple readings at
multiple points so you can look at this
travel time from here to here and you
can ask what's their average speed and
the answer is the average speed between
plazas is in the region of 60 miles an
hour average speed is barely affected so
speed but then these plazas the plazas
were designed not to slow you down at
all how can it be that the system is
sampling at a stationary point along the
road and getting a nun representative
reading my best guess is that it's
something along these lines that tried
to make it so that this monitoring is
unintrusive but what actually happens is
that there'll be four percent of
vehicles who don't have RFID and they
have to go to an exit lane go into the
cache booth then they have to merge back
on so that merging in and out it causes
the shock waves which cause slow down
and then the shock waves have some
extent and the extent varies over the
course of the day the the this this
period of perturbation will be no it
kicks in at a certain time of day 4pm
5pm some days it doesn't kick in and
then it's like if you have an army
marching along they're going along silly
and then they walk into treacle and then
they much long normal speed again so
there's no real impact on throughput but
there is a big hit on speed at those
those time today that's my best guess
from the data
get hyper space where well I'm guessing
that people are merging in and it's got
some knock-on effect Falls and then as
you say the shock waves are heading
backwards so that's why i drew this line
going backward because i'm imagining
their shock waves pushing back I don't
know the trouble is this is a non
measurable thing now we only have
measurements at this instant so so how
can you stitch together this is just
just a best guess based on piecing
together those piece of information
anyway this is this is a example which
really stresses this point billing data
is the only data that is mitica c
collected sometimes it is collected so
meticulously that it destroys the system
that you're you're measuring and then
the fourth rule of the database are if
you build a desirable platform you get
much richer data so now on to give a
next example last example
they saw me the incentive platform this
is something that balaji touched on when
a user signed up to the incentive so
well a user signs up to the incentive
scheme they signed something which says
okay we are now going to grant you
access to historical trip roads records
from before you signed up and so for all
the users we have what 300 and something
thousand users and we have very very
long records for a lot of them what what
really the topic of this incentive
scheme is is how can you get people to
shift their behavior and there are some
types of shift which are steady pressure
and there are some types of shift which
are catch people at the key moment when
they're ready to be persuaded there is
there's pop psychology literature about
habit formation I didn't know where to
look for scientific stuff about habit
formation but if you're designing an
incentive scheme that's truly the best
place to be get them at the point where
they're on the verge of changing the
habits target them with a lot of nudging
then and then hopefully you'll have won
them for a period of time or it could go
the other way if there's someone who's
who's had reasonably good behavior and
they are about to experience something
very bad which will put them off off
public transit for the next however long
that's the point where you really need
to worry about them and what I'm going
to describe here is a pretty brain-dead
model but it's something which tells us
something interesting this is something
that was done by an intern so were a
couple of years ago here's what they did
said i'll call it nu t be the number of
work days monday to friday in a given
week on which they use a you major
morning trip so our incentive scheme was
targeted around trying to reduce the
peak congestion in the in the morning
rush hour so so so I mean look in the
morning let's just just stick in the the
most Brendan model we can possibly
imagine which has some element of
stickiness so I'm going to fit the model
there nu TB
alpha u + b2 you n UT minus one plus
plus a nice so if I'm a user who's
really habitual and I always do the same
this week as I did last week then i
would expect be to you to be pretty
close to one and if i'm a user who every
week is it so new challenge then i'd
expect be to you to be pretty much zero
so these parameters alpha and beta are
the most brain-dead way we can get to
get the first cut of stickiness and user
behavior I had been dead several times
what I really mean is this is a
statistical model it's trying to be a
fit to extract some parameters of
interest it's not a generative model
it's nothing like you'd use if you're
writing a simulator but it's it's good
for descriptive purposes not generative
purposes so fridge I plotted one dot for
each user each of the three hundred
thousand users alpha for each user is on
the x-axis and beta is on the y-axis and
there are quite a few people with this
beat us pretty high and if I pick a
sample of these people up here if I pick
a sample of the users with a high beta
IE with strong that they get stuck in a
rut I just picked out a group of people
with high values of beta and I plotted a
sample of them each panel here is a
different user the x-axis bands a period
of about three years and the y-axis I
say each tick on the x-axis is one week
the White this is the number of a number
of days each week that they may do a
commuting there's an awful lot of this
sort of behavior you have the stretch
this is about three months where you're
doing four or five trips a week and then
you go off it and then you go on it
one off on off public transport on off
on and what I really love about this is
that when you look up in the transport
modeling literature there's an awful lot
of stuff about discrete choice models
the standard discrete choice model is
basically a one-shot model you have some
sort of logistic regression which says
based on this person's characteristic
the probability they will take public
transport is p1 the probability they
take your car is p 2 and so on their
formula for working out p 1 p 2 based on
things like age drop distance to work
those are one shot models and those are
great for generating independent samples
each time of day but if you're someone
who's interested in changing what people
do you care about longitudinal models
and you really care about what this is
this is very first peek into longitude
modules i think the reason why transport
model is don't even consider things like
this is the way they collect their data
is they do a survey every five years
you'd send out a survey you collect data
for one or two days you get that and if
you have isolated snapshot data or you
can possibly build as an isolated
snapshot model but if you're in the
database are where you have built a
platform which enables you to connect
massive longitudinal data sets that's
what enables you to to learn long-term
patterns of behavior gives you access to
much much richer data
okay so so that's next to lesson from
the date of bizarre lesson three was
that billing records are kept very
carefully everything else you have to
work at it the final lesson was that if
you build a platform or if you're
engaged in the building of platform if
you make the platform desirable to users
then you will get way more rich
interesting data and have the ability to
tweak the rules to to to learn learn
much more so let me in the next got ten
minutes left I've talked about some of
the challenges of working with data in
the bazaar I'll finish by talking about
what sort of tools we want to have to
work with this sort of data and a number
of are certainly me used to be one of
the briefs in the cathedral who says
they just we discussed the gas on the
living the bus system
we talked up there and like horrible
community experience the trains make the
bus unfortunately can get the data to
the sound again
it could be they switch the bus I know
when I was in London I do that in
retrospect I can't really figure out why
it is that I'd take the tube for for a
month at a stretch and then suddenly
start taking the bus I just can't figure
out why I did it then I'd switch to
taking the bike for a long time okay so
I'd certain used to be one of these
people though the priests of the
Cathedral who said that proving limit
serums but the people who work in the
bazaar what I'm really keen on what I
wanted to build is basically an Excel
for big data Excel is one of the most
amazing modeling tools but we don't sit
around have conferences about how using
Excel to model letters let's look stupid
people who have actual problems of their
own lego and use Excel and they solve
the modeling problems and yet yet
somehow the tools for working with big
data to understand these things are not
accessible enough not accessible to the
same sort of people who could use Excel
so I want to highlight some features
which I think will push towards that
direction so what I am very very keen on
it is modeling done by domain experts
not not welding done by theoreticians
but theoreticians creating appropriate
tools the domain experts can use because
domain experts are the ones who
understand the ins and outs of the
nitty-gritty stuff of their system they
want crew dancers to richer questions
then you can get from theorems when
you're trying to work with theorem to
come to a certain point and say oh I
can't prove a theorem here so let's use
simulation then why not just give
simulation tools to everyone okay let me
let me be a bit more concrete let me let
me say briefly what I think some high
points were 1990s is when glm came on
board and all of a sudden you have this
this language this really expressive
formula language which lets you write
out a modeling formula using only the
variables in your data I either
variables you have created yourself and
by small permutations of the formula you
write out you can express really rich
ideas that was a massive leap forward
making those sorts of things accessible
to everyday users
in the 2000s that's when bootstrap
became computationally feasible and it's
when good visualization theory came on
board leading to good visualization
packages particularly d3 and Jeju plot
so that's that's that's the past the the
present Big Data machine learning
reconstruction we've heard a fair bit
about reconstruction now so so I won't
repeat that but let me draw a quick
picture of big data and machine learning
is applied to control problems this is a
picture of a of what you do if you were
thinking of a control problem but you
didn't believe that Kalman filtering was
appropriate state variable XT which
updates itself control variables which
come in and observations which come out
but let's think of this is just some
arbitrary complicated neural network
which we want to train from the data so
what I'm saying here is that I'm
interested in really understanding what
makes users shift their behavior I have
no confidence whatsoever that I could
come up with any equations to describe
it so instead I'll throw it open to the
neural network to learn the patterns and
if I have loads and loads of data then
these things will be able to learn
something useful and what these neural
networks when the trend properly will
end up in coding is how much history
needs to be kept from one time step to
another where habituation lives all
these sorts of things bootstrap was
basically a way of trying to win people
away from using parametric equations
saying don't use parameter it models
just use the data as it is this is this
is a model so it's not quite it is not
completely nonparametric but your
networks have so many parameters that
you can't possibly interpret them so if
we as muddlers have finally given up our
attachment to parametric models then
then this is an easy fit
and I'm by no means an expert on this
there are papers around and i think i
think the techniques were solving these
things training them are just beginning
to be available oh so that's what that's
what the president looks like all of the
near future and what i'm most excited
about for what comes next i right call
it causal inference in bootstrap
simulation um there was a question that
was a question earlier today but I've
forgotten who asked it so sorry just
skip over what do I mean by causal
inference and rather than trying to
define it i'm going to give an example
this is the game that Balaji showed you
each user has a piece on the board and
when you have earned enough points
through your travel you click on the
spinner and the spinner stops and your
piece moves forwards so now let's take
the entire data set of everyone and
let's look at all the people who happen
to be at this spot out of those people
to 16 of them will hit this piece
because their roller 2 and five six of
them will not hit that hit that prize
money so therefore what I have here if I
look at that subset of Daejeon I make
some fairly reasonable assumptions about
time dependence I have a mini randomized
controlled experiment sitting there
inside my data and there was a question
of blood least awkward where someone
said can you do randomized experiments
could you like site let people sign up
but they're not really sign them up it
you can do all sorts of things sometimes
when people get wind of it like when
when you learn that amazon is giving you
higher prices than other people you feel
myth buy it so so when you're doing
these experiments sometimes you try and
introduce them subtly sometimes you take
advantage of the natural variation that
there is inside the system this is
economists call this a natural
experiment a natural experiment is one
where you have a mini randomized trial
just embedded in the data you have so
this user got a three these are missed
out there in the non-winning arm so we
know that spins are truly eggs or
generously random their mini randomized
trials they control how much you use the
winds so it's this knowledge which gives
us the causal link which says if you win
then you will do such and such we can we
can treat this as a genuine stimulus and
it's it's these causal links that become
the basis for a generative model that
become the basis for a simulation tool
so what I think the future looks like is
will be collecting these massive fine
grained longitudinal data sets they have
to be fine grained I think because
otherwise these sorts of automated
techniques about discovering
randomized trials they just don't work
if they're if they're aggregates and
they don't walk if work if you have
snapshots of the data so we need huge
huge data sets the muddler will do the
same sort of thing they did with the glm
tools you write some broad structural
thing saying I the muddler assert that
this is a random thing within within the
data set and then the Machine goes away
and and it figures out the generative
dynamics of the system in a bootstrap II
sort of way it figures out well if I
wanted to run a simulation I could I
could bootstrap it by taking a
collection of traitors from other users
who experienced the similar condition
and and and build those up to form a
simulator so that's what I think that's
what I think the next big things will be
as using big data to to make modelling
accessible to people who want to just
answer trickier more practical more
immediate questions and I'll finish with
one loss slide stephen boyd on monday is
the phrase that he said people want
engineering that starts from nothing and
just works Ned woodleigh gave the
example of Boeing we just and what do
you trust a neural network to fly a
plane for you that you get on a plane
which was trained in the in the way I've
described based on simulation and neural
network
another counter to that is to say
there's no way this could ever fly
because it simply doesn't have anywhere
near the real-time control bounds needed
to make something truly fly reliably so
if we believe Edward Lee this will never
fly I think I think that societal
networks just need this kind of
engineering they need engineering which
is greater coping with noise greater
coping with richness and greater letting
people try things up for themselves
without without getting hung up in
theorems or a girl or tightness just
just you know try something and if it
doesn't work then you build your system
a bit differently and you gather more
data ok ok
thank you